me mark and kevin o'connell the
offensive coordinator for the rams
uh we actually tp'ed nick mangold's
house while we all played together
on the podcast oh wow and we totally
revealed it tonight
like a bunch of kids and [ __ ] he had an
infant and it was on thanksgiving and
his family was all there were they
pissed oh dude
we didn't tell him this was 2012. we
didn't we told him eight years later
just told him on the podcast a week ago
what do you say he said he wasn't happy
i almost forgot about that but i was
really pissed and we were like
sorry all right man thanks for coming on
we were planning on
telling him at the time yeah we're gonna
oh so we go to pick him up the next
morning
this one you guys are all playing for
the jets yes goes can you believe this
[ __ ]
i think these giants kids down the
street these fans
they they did this oh i hate these look
at how hot
like we threw it up and you gotta figure
out what this is
mark sanchez threw it up there so we
were like oh no
like this is bad he's actually mad he
goes i got my son here like
my newborn baby my uh in-laws are all
here
everybody's like picking up stuff we
were doing like i'd be so mad
thanksgiving pre-christmas stuff all
this kind of stuff going on and we're
just like ooh
this was bad so i literally look in the
rear view mirror to see scotty in the
back seat as he's getting in the thing
and i'm like
don't tell him well he also dude that's
uh he also did it dude i'm sorry he said
something he goes
i mean look how high it is like were
these guys like water pool
players or what when we're like
waterproof
throwers or something yep you don't
think one maybe played quarterback
sc to get it up there nick two nfl
quarterbacks was he pissed and i kind of
got a hose too yeah you have a good arm
now you have that scarf on it doubles as
a mask but you
you like this fashion i know you're such
a [ __ ]
you're like a [ __ ] like you're like
hey you're like one person that
like if there wasn't covert or covert
was officially dead tomorrow
you'd still rock it because you'd be
like well just in case
exactly but you're like that's a fashion
it's a billy the king
now you can't say [ __ ] what are you
gonna do no you can't
do whatever you want you can't do
anything and you can do [ __ ] dumb as
[ __ ]
as long as you got this on because you
wanted to wear that before
corona but you just never had the ball
give me excuses like the
the thing like the the tie i match it
with the fit
what's up doug it's an accessory now you
came in the travis scott
yeah goddamn it's cause i know you like
to drip on them so i was like
because you you know i usually just rock
my new balances but i i [ __ ] with my
jordan
but but i was like let me just let me
just let me just there's like a little
like a stiff jab to your face it's like
an older brother move like boom like
oh just like we both got trapped scots
on [ __ ] wildfires out here
were supposedly caused by somebody doing
a gender reveal
party for whatever reason this happened
it happened in arizona
but can i say first of all you know what
happened to the guy in arizona he got
the 200 000
fine 200 000. i want everyone to listen
to this very specific
is this the camera that's it hey is that
my camera nobody
gives a [ __ ] what gender your baby's
gonna be no you don't need to throw
parties
not listen the only i don't if it's a
race reveal party i'll go like if you
have a black guy an asian guy and a
white guy oh that'd be cool and the
woman's like we're going to hit the
balloon
i would i would watch that i would go to
that party yeah but if you invite me to
a gender reveal party we're not friends
anymore no
i remember all we all we did is my
brother-in-law stephen brought over a
cupcake
and we bit into it but but listen even
that was a little much for me
i was like i don't i don't mind you just
celebrating your finger in it but i
don't mind celebrating you're having a
baby good for you
i don't give oh [ __ ] what sex your baby
technics
to release the [ __ ] jet [ __ ] out how
self-important do you think you need to
invite 50 people over you know what
you don't have [ __ ] else going on it's
so dumb you don't have
[ __ ] else going on you got to throw a
party
with pyrotechnics and you know what is
even worse
and who was like yeah let's do it out
here in the middle and we know it's hot
in the summer
and let's have some firecrackers and how
about be how about the people who
like the the guy who hits the balloon
and it's pink and he's visibly
disappointed i'm like yeah bro your kid
is going to see that
well how about the your kid is going to
be like you didn't want me well how
about that not at the moment
how about the dumbass when they toss
them the balloon and he strikes out
i mean it's and it breaks on the ground
and they're like oh it's a boy
yeah it's so well dude how about how
about if let's say you're doing a gender
reveal party
in the mountains and you started a fire
that costs millions and millions of
dollars in tragedy and killed lies
that baby i mean it's just not a good
sign what are you gonna name that baby
diablo yeah and fuego
yeah it's influential yeah you have to
do something with fire it
it's so dumb the the
baby business and what is available for
babies and what parents do and what they
buy
to me is so over the top the amount of
money that people pay on their kids
birthday parties
over the top can you imagine your
dad setting up a camera in your room
because he wanted to watch you all the
time
just just as a matter of fact when he
went into your room i'm going to tell
you what he was thinking
thank god i don't get to talk to that
[ __ ] guy for until tomorrow 100
that's what we were all thinking but no
but you know now we have cameras
in the room because yeah kid cries from
like that it's crazy dude
it's all access all the time and i just
i don't think it's good for parents or
kids
that's not healthy separation is is a
little bit yeah you know what i mean
but then also like my son he keeps
waking up at like 4 30
5 a.m and i'm an early riser so i don't
mind it
but then the other morning he walked in
the room and woke me up
and i was like all right here we go and
i was kind of rested and i got all my
[ __ ] together we're going to just pop
let's go downstairs and make coffee like
alright
i'm walking down i look at my phone it's
1am
i was like what the hell are you doing
dude does he like making coffee with you
yeah he loves it
that's awesome so i go dude you got to
go back to bed it's like it's one tiger
you gotta wait to at least five he's
like oh okay and then the next one i go
dude
why you keep getting up so early man he
goes i don't have a clock
i don't have a clock i went i went
and this is the one you guys hated l.a
county has said that they're canceling
halloween by
not allowing people to trick-or-treat
have parties carnivals
the whole nine and what is the f what's
the uh
what happens if you don't know what's
gonna happen can you dress up in your
own home
i think that might be okay but you might
get your water shut off
wow no way did you hear about the tick
tockers they got
they threw a huge party in the hollywood
hills and a couple days later they had
their power and water shut off
yeah for i think close to a week
you can do that uh the mayor of l.a did
it i don't know if he
could but he did it he did it
it's insane no worries someone has lost
his goddamn mind i don't hate anybody on
this earth
but i would suck newsome in the day that
would hurt his dick
because you you talk really hard real
hard sock yeah
might explode i hope some danger shits
on new some i can't stand them
you cancel halloween it's my kids
favorite holiday dude
yeah what would you what would you dress
up that's just in l.a county you can go
out to like riverside and
i'm i'm sure orange county downstairs
orange county
halloween's popping off down there i
can't i gotta drive an hour with my kid
i could wear the [ __ ] suit
i'm wario we'll get you like are you you
can come hang out with us
we don't need it we're good we'll all be
in suits
also halloween everyone's a mask anyways
that's true worried about it
and kids can't spread it's a [ __ ]
that's a weird hallway holiday for them
to cancel then
it's the one where people wear masks how
about i bet christmas is next
christmas you can't get anyone having
christmas at their house we're gonna cut
off their water
[Music]
way to ruin the day i'm sorry i just
needed you to know before you got your
water shut off yeah i'm wario for
halloween though my son's mario
you could say whatever you wanted your
brother and your brother to him but
somebody outside
says it to you or says my brother beat
the [ __ ] out of me but if someone did
mess with me then you have to mess with
the big brother and he would [ __ ] you up
so but it was weird though because he
hated me so at home it was
awful dude but then if someone messed
with me outside you didn't offend me
you know my oldest brother was six years
older than me
and i was in third grade once and this
kid was picking on me this dude
was large i'm not sure if i told you
this before large
and he was the biggest and he used to
pick me up and bear hug me and
yeah right and i just and i had nothing
i could do and nobody you know
he was the biggest kid in class and
teacher wasn't doing anything and i
remember i mentioned it a couple times
at dinner
and i could just see my brother oldest
brother he was in ninth grade at the
time
just shaking his head the whole time so
one day we come in from recess
and my brother ninth grade and in ninth
grade my brother had john mcenroe hair
like this was the time sick and wore a
headband
ninth grader man and he was sitting
there with one of his friends
coming from recess and the teacher's
there and i look at my brother and she
goes can i help you i go that's my
brother
i'm really good which one is he y'all
wait what i go what he goes which one
who keeps picking on you and i go him
my brother him my brother walks up and
goes let me tell you something
if you touch my brother one more [ __ ]
time
when i come back here i'm going to kick
your ass
and the teacher did it the teacher was
like hey you can't and said something
like that and he looked right at her and
did he said shut up [ __ ]
you did your [ __ ] job i wouldn't have
had to come in here he said that
out louder what a game if you did your
[ __ ] was this the drug dealer
no no
no it wasn't but he was flat out if you
did your [ __ ] by the way this guy
this brother lives in santa monica and
got the [ __ ]
beat out of him during the protests for
trying to protect the business down here
not even his business oh wow
he called me he was like oh i'm in pain
and what's going on he goes i just got
beat up by a bunch of
like what were you doing man he goes i
was trying to protect the business i go
was it your business did you go by a
bunch of skilled guys yeah i was like
what
i got beat up by a bunch of skilled guys
kill players i'm such a protesting
yeah they're really fast and jump hype
what
you mean a bunch of black guys beat up
okay slim reaper come on
sick the best seven footer slim reaper
seven footer the reaper the reaper's ill
and how about he gets on uh
social media he's got burner accounts he
got burned but how many minutes
do you have none i'm not i don't really
mess with it at all anymore you don't
have any burner accounts never
never oh i
i do it there and then i got that burner
life i'm how about skip bayless with the
burner life but his
isn't like going at trolls his is
he he got caught because he thought he
was out of the uh his other account but
he's in his original account
so he's like skip you're the best man i
can't believe people are hating on you
you're the best analyst in the game
but he did it from his original what was
this recently probably
two years ago i'm all about that burner
account you should do a cough
like a like but but but also you got to
bring it back to like my first
appearance because i was coughing what
you do no you're fine it's right
antibodies